dr fauci in his own mind symbolizes  truth it's called the fouchy effect  which is sort of like you know  as  trust me i'm i i don't get excited about  that  i mean it's nice but i mean  it's it's  i  people go to medical school  now people are interested in science not  because of me because people most people  don't know me who i am my friends know  me my wife knows me but people don't  know me it's what i symbolize  i symbolize truth i love that first part  the false modesty in the first part  listen people are saying and i don't get  any thrill out of this okay this is a  man who in a documentary that was made  about him is shown sitting in front of  his home computer with a giant portrait  of himself on the wall but no this man  he doesn't like to think about adulation  or praise no no no not not a little dr  vaj